hey guys Pete here this is my 10 things
you might have missed video for Twin
Peaks season 3 episode 6 this will be
your spoiler warning everything beyond
this will spoil part 6 of the return if
you haven't watched it yet alright first
thing the names on the documents that
were in Dougie's Case Files you remember
we saw him he gets a little bit of help
with some dots of light and we see Doug
you two making some markings all the
files we see have Anthony and Claire's
name on them that's Tony that we met in
his office
played by time Tom Sizemore and we also
see him make a big mark next to the
investigating officers on one of the
documents which are listed as Detective
Loomis and detective Stockton so no
clear understanding of what's going on
but bud his boss wanted him to look at
these particular files they all seem to
be claims that Tony has made and these
officers may be important in relation to
some sort of fraud scam the next one is
the one-one-nine drugged-out mother
turns out to be reused footage from part
three now I mentioned this in my recap
and review that I put out two days ago
and not sure what it means it could be a
situation where they didn't shoot enough
footage of her or something like that so
they just had to reuse it but as you can
see here they are the same clip of her
saying one-one-nine with the pill in the
bottle in part 3 she goes on to take
that pill in this episode 6 she doesn't
so something to think about there number
3 if you hadn't noticed this is Heidi
Heidi from the original run in both
instances where we see her 25 years ago
and today she mostly just giggles
remember Shelley had said something
about her being too busy jump-starting
the old man when her car wasn't start
was her excuse for being late so yeah
she's been in the series before and
she's back and she's still giggling
number 4 the mention of dr. Bend I say
that this may be
important only because the way that
Jamie brings it up it sounds like the
original dougie had seen this doctor in
the past we don't know anything else
about him but you remember she made a
statement that she was going to take
dougie coupe there at lunchtime but then
she wasn't able to because she had to
make the pay off for his loans number
five the name Linda I'm sure most people
did actually notice this but in case you
didn't we get a new character named
Mickey he says he's going into town for
Linda's mail from the post office she
seems to be disabled and call said
something in relation to her going to
war so the giant said remember four
three zero Richard and Linda two birds
with one stone so this is most likely
Linda in relation to Richard horn being
Richard number six when Richard horn is
driving speaking of Richard horn away
from the hit-and-run
we see electrical lines and a telephone
pole reflected in his windshield we also
hear the electrical noise when they show
up it's not a hundred percent clear if
these things are really there or if
they're just a clue like a visual clue
that we see because when he gets out of
the car we don't see that he's near any
or there aren't any telephone poles in
the frame anyway so it's hard to say but
it seems pretty important that they're
there and they're not only just there
but they're kind of pointed out if you
missed them by the sound you can clearly
hear the sound if you're wearing
headphones like I was number seven the
same intersection where the hit-and-run
happens is the one where Mike pulls up
to Leland and Laura and fire walk with
me now it's in the same town so this may
not be anything of significance other
than you know they're in place you would
see places again but it was an intense
scene in fire walk with me and basically
Mike was saying that you stole a can of
corn and it's not 100% clear if he's
talking to Bob that seems like you would
be because I don't understand how Leland
would be a
to do that but you know it caused Laura
to be upset
it caused Leland to not be able to
explain what was going on and now we see
that same area again in number eight
related to that same area we also see
the same markings on this telephone pole
that we did from fire walk with me and
this these markings were on a pole that
were in the fat trout now the the
meaning of this is is obscure four on
purpose some things that are important I
guess dimension is that it's not the
exact same pole it just has the same
markings whenever it hands up you hear
the sound the same sound that I
mentioned that we heard whenever we saw
the pole and Richard horns reflection on
his windshield but it's not the same one
that we hear whenever you see the pole
and the lines inspire walk with me so
I'll get to that in a minute but just
wanting to make it clear that it's not
the exact same telephone pole in the
same place this appears to be near that
intersection where the hit-and-run
happened but again there's nothing that
says that is the case for sure
so yeah nine is that sound the sound
that we hear I called it a lexical home
so I'm really a hum it's more like a
crackling or something and I was
interested in this because when we saw
the telephone lines in relation to the
telephone pole in fire walk with me
whenever we saw them we heard the sound
of the arm you know the arm whenever he
introduced himself said this is the
sound that I make and it's sort of a
looping sound and that's what we heard
and fire walk with me when we saw the
electrical lines here the sound is
different and I went back intact it's
not the sound at Italian place and
honestly I can't say for sure but the
first time I noticed this sound in
season three was when we saw the Statue
that eventually came in the red room
obviously that eventually came to be the
arms doppelganger so this sound may be
the sound of the arms doppelganger
because we do actually hear the
evolution of the arm sound which again
is
the same as the old one but it's
different than this one so if anybody
has done any more investigation and
knows when we first heard this out for
sure please let me know in the comments
let's keep it let's keep an eye on when
these kinds of sounds happen what
they're what we think they're related to
and there's a lot of speculation that
can come out of that and the final thing
you might have missed is the sign out
front of the fat trout trailer park it
does have a new on it now I've mentioned
this in videos from before because this
was one of the original you know shots
that they showed him the few trailers we
had and I noticed it right away there
may be a back story of how the fat trout
got to where it is or there may not be
it's kind of conflicting like the in the
secret history it just sort of mentions
call rod coming back to the Twin Peaks
area in silent walk with me deer meadow
does not seem to be in the media area of
area of Twin Peaks it seems to be in the
south near Oregon so this little new
sign might just be there to give it a
story fix you know so there isn't if
anybody was confused of why it moved or
it could just be that there will be a
story later on down the road of why call
rod lose the entire trailer park closer
to Twin Peaks a couple of bonus things
the Nez Perce sign or the tag or
whatever you call that on the door if
you're not sure about Nez Perce if you
haven't read the secret history one
thing that we know from that is that a
chief from that tribe a guy named
twisted hair is the person who first
gave the Al Cave ring to Lewis and Clark
so that tribe is mysterious for other
reasons as well but it's you know that's
Hawks heritage and the ring the green
ring that we've seen the origin story
from secret history as it came from them
another thing is that there is some
weird stuff stuff with the sonny jim
scene in this episode as well i'm still
really not sure to make what to make of
it all there was
long post an explanation on reddit where
they show that they show his footage
they show part of it forward and then in
the next thing they show that same thing
backwards so they were using footage
again it brings up questions because
it's related to sunny Jim who people
have you know speculated on before I'm
really not sure it's there there's
something there I think and I just don't
know I mean he could be with the thumbs
up and the whole thing he could be like
the you know the season three's version
of the waiter that is known as senior
senior thrill Cup but we're just gonna
have to keep an eye on see what happens
so okay that's it I will be likely doing
a QA this weekend and so leave all your
questions in comments I hope you liked
the video please give it a like if you
did please subscribe to my channel and
thank you for watching I'll talk to you
soon